السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته.
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
[Silence]
حي على صلاه
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا
ومن سيئات اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا.
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون.
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله وخير
الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر شر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
alles to الله
forgiv
الله guides
canever
الله leavesay
can gu
i be witness that there is no worthy of
worshipcept
and
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
standing
of your
day of judgement
hear him
hearing him
speak to you
calling
‏name
الحمد لله
asl
we love to go toانه
we ask to meet
prom
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
فمن كان يرجو لقاء ربه
فليعمل عملا صالحا ولا يشرك بعباده ربه
احدا
هو whoever
‏deeds
and associate none in their worship of
their Lord.
Even if you feel otherwise imagining
this event
today, right now we still have that
chance.
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏sin
my sister
proud
and
‏ch us to be
he ch you to be gu
to understand your
clearly
and to acc to divine
we are not ord people
you areal
because you carry with you theage of isl
صلى الله عليه وسلم
خيركم من تعلم القران وعلمه
قران
الله سبحانه وتعالى مازسن قران
افلا يتدبرون القران ام على قلوب اقفالها
notر
‏are
you have a chance
nobody knows
when the end of our life nobody knows
the last
‏take
small
even
understand
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏small
but now الله
those
even
smalls
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
us every strugle
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم الذي يقرا القران
وهو ماهر به
هو مع السفره الكرام البرره والذي يقرا
القران ويتعتع فيه وهو عليه شاق له اجران
ران
[Silence]
‏every letter you
every effort you make
reward by
multiplies rewards infinitely beyond
ourhion
being mindful when reading the ر
[Silence]
‏of Allah's mercy.
Allow your heart to feel that mercy.
When youite a verse about the day of
judgement, imagine standing before
the quر not just touch your lips, but
more your heart
and shape your action.
‏So when we read the Quran
we should not for the application
this mindfulness
also
سبحان الله
mind
سبحانه وتالى
الحمد لله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الله
gen
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏need him
and
out of
mercy and love reward and bless
abundant
those
draw closer to
‏sincerity we have to be sincere
it's not something okay I'm just do this
behind my back and that's
my brother and sister
never under the power of small
consistent
الله سبحانه
صلى الله عليه وسلم احب الاعمال الى الله
ادومها وان قلب
‏intention
and resolve to connect
with the quران and let guidance
transform your lives
you are you are
and you be proud of your entity
race
‏and
as we said we have to understand
ourigion
let comm today brothers and sisters to
reconnect with ourigion to our hearts to
theران
‏and to proudly
live as Muslims reflecting the beauty of
Islam to our actions and interactions.
‏And so when we come to the prayer, we
know what the ising and the spe of Allah
subانه wa the word of
talking tole of us
sincerity
ours and make us among those carage
with the worldfall
الله العظيم لي ولكم فاستغفروه انه هو
الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف الانبياء والمرسلين نبينا محمد
عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
اما بعد
اخوتي الكرام تخيلوا معي انفسكم واقفين
امام خالقكم يوم القيامه
وانتم تسمعون الله سبحانه يخاطبكم مباشره
باسمائكم
كيف سيكون
شعوركم في تلك اللحظه
الحمد لله نحن كمسلمين نحب لقاء الله
سبحان الله سبحانه وتعالى ونشتاق لهذا
اللقاء
لان الله وعدنا باجور عظيمه لا توصف
ولهذا هذا يقول الله تعالى فمن كان يرجو
لقاء ربه فليعمل عملا صالحا ولا يشرك
بعباده ربه احدا
حتى
ان كان ردك على هذا السؤال مختلفا
فما زالت الفرصه قائمه
الان واليوم هو الوقت الانسب للبدء الله
سبحانه وتعالى يفرح بتوبه من يعود اليه
بصدق واخلاص
يا ايها الاخوه والاخوات يجب علينا ان
نفتخر ونعتز بكوننا مسلمين فالله اختارنا
ان نكون
مسلمين وهدانا لطريق واضح ومنهج مستقيم
ومنح ومنحنا شرف حمل هذه الرساله العظيمه
رساله الاسلام التي تحمل هدايه ورحمه
للبشريه اجمعين
تذكروا حديث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
خيركم من تعلم القران وعلمه
يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى في كتابه العزيز
افلا يتدبرون القران ام على قلوب اقفالها
لذلك
اعقد قد اليوم عهدا مع انفسكم ان تبداوا
خطوه صغيره
ان تبداوا خطوه ولو صغيره
حتى لو كانت دقيقه واحده فقط في اليوم
تتعلمون فيها شيئا جديدا من القران ايه
واحده حرفا واحد
او تدبرا واحدا
ابداوا الان فالله يحب الذين يسعون اليه
حتى لو بخطوات صغيره وقد بشرنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بان من يجد صعوبه في تعلم
القران له اجر مضاعف
فقد قال صلى الله عليه وسلم الذي يقرا
القران وهو ماهر به مع السفره الكرام
البرره والذي يقرا القران ويتعتع فيه وهو
عليه شاق له اجران رواه مسلم كل حرف تقرا
وكل جكل جهد تبذل هو محفوظ ومضاعف عند
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اخوتي واخواتي التدبر في القران يعني ان
تربطوا قلوبكم وعقولكم بمعانيه العظيمه
ليس مجرد تلاوه
بل فهم وتامل وانعكاس في حياتكم
عندما تقراون القران عن رحمه
فلتستشعروا بعمق هذه الرحمه في قلوبكم
وعندما نمر بايات عن يوم الحساب
فنتخيل انفسنا واقفين امام الله سبحانه
وتعالى
اجعلوا القران نورا يغير حياتكم واخلاقكم
واعمالكم
وهذا التدبر ويجب ان يمد او ان يمتد ايضا
الى اذكاركم اليوميه
عندما نقول سبحان الله
فلنشعر بعظمه الله وكماله في قلوبنا
وعندما نقول الحمد لله فلنستشعر حقا
الامتنان في
النعمه والعظمه
والكثره
التي اعطانا الله سبحانه وتعالى وعندما
نقول اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم نستشعر
اعتمادنا الكامل على حمايه الله
واثقين واثقين انه وحده القادر على
حمايتنا الله سبحانه وتعالى غني عن
عبادتنا ولكننا نحن من نحتاج اليه دائما
وابدا
ورغم ذلك من رحمته ولطفه انه يكافئنا
ويضاعف الاجر لكل من يقترب اليه بصدق
لا تستهينوا ابدا
باثر الاعمال الصغيره المستمره يقول الله
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم احب
الاعمال الى الله ادومها وان قلب رواه
البخاري
اليوم عاهدوا انفسكم بنيه صادقه
وعزيمه قويه ان تتصلوا مره اخرى بالقران
الكريم
وان تدعوا
هديه وان تدعوا هديه يغير حياتكم
نحو الافضل
انتم مسلمون
فافتخروا هذا
واعتزوا
وعززوا هويتكم
وانشروا جمال الاسلام من خلال كلماتكم
وافعالكم واخلاقكم
التي نتعلمها من القران
اللهم ارزقنا الاخلاص اللهم ارزقنا
الاخلاص واهد قلوبنا
واجعلنا ممن يحملون رسالتك
بكل فخر للعالمين
عباد الله ان الله وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين اللهم
اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا
عذاب النار ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون
فاذكروا الله العظيم الجليل يذكركم
واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر
والله يعلم ما تصنعون واقيموا الصلاه
اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووا
استقيموا وتراصوا سدوا الخلل
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
الله وملائكته
يصلون
على
النبي
يا ايها الذين امنوا
صلوا عليه
صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما
ان
الذين يؤدون الله ورسوله
لعنهم الله
لعنهم الله في الدنيا والاخره
واعد لهم عذابا
مهينا
والذين
يؤدون
المؤمنين
والمؤمنات
بغير ما اكتسبوا
فقد احتملوا
بهتانا
واثما
مبينا.
يا
ايها
النبي قل لازواجك
وبناتك
ونساء
المؤمنين
قل لازواجك
وبناتك ونساء
المؤمنين يدنين عليهن
يدنين
عليهن
من جلابيبهن
ذلك ادنى
ان يعرفن فلا يؤذين
وكان الله غفورا
رحيما
الله الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
المنافقون
والذين في قلوبهم
مرض والمرجفون
في المدينه
والمرجفون
في المدينه لنغرينك
بهم
ثم لا يجاورونك
فيها
الا قليلا
ملعونين
اينما ثقفوا
اخذوا وقتلوا تقيلا
سنه الله في الذين خلوا من
قبل ولن تجد لسنه
الله تبديلا
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
في ش
عاوز بس